- [Instructor] In other videos,
we have talked about the idea that,
even for a given element,
you might have different
versions of that element,
and we call those different
versions isotopes.
And each isotope of an element
can have a different atomic mass.
And that stems from the idea
that, if it's a given element,
it's going to have the
same number of protons,
but you could have a
different number of neutrons.
Now one question that you might
have been asking yourself is
how have chemists been able to figure out
what the various isotopes
of an element are
and their relative abundance?
What percentage of an element that we find
in the universe is of isotope A
versus, say, isotope B?
And the answer to your question is
they use a technique known
as mass spectrometry.
I can never say it
right, mass spectrometry.
Sometimes you'll hear the
word mass spectroscopy,
and they're essentially
referring to the same idea.
And what this technique is,
is that you put a little bit
of a sample right over here,
let's say we're talking about
zirconium in this example,
and you heat it up.
So you have it,
you have a bunch of the
zirconium floating around,
and then you beam it.
You will bombard it with
a bunch of electrons.
And what the electron bombardment does is,
it can knock off electrons
from the atoms in your sample,
and it can ionize them.
And by ionizing some of your
atoms, they now have charge.
And because they have charge,
they can be accelerated
through these electric plates.
So now you have these ions,
in this case, of zirconium,
moving quite rapidly through this chamber,
and then they enter into a magnetic field.
And a magnetic field, a
strong magnetic field,
can bend the path, can
deflect ions with charge.
For a given charge,
the force of the deflection
will be the same.
But if you have a larger mass,
you're going to be deflected less.
And if you have a lower mass,
you're going to be deflected more.
And so what you see here
are the different isotopes being
deflected different amounts
as they go through the magnetic field.
And then you have the detector.
And at different points of the detector,
you will detect each of these isotopes.
And the more ions that hit a
certain part of the detector,
that means that, hey, I have more
of that type of isotope in nature.
And then from that,
you can generate a chart
that looks like this,
where you see, on the horizontal axis,
sometimes you'll see
it labeled atomic mass.
And here, it's in unified
atomic mass units.
And you can see, when
you put the zirconium
through the mass spectrometer like this,
you get a little bit that
has a mass number of 96,
you have a little bit more
that gets a mass number of 94,
92, 91, and most of the
zirconium, over 50%,
has a mass number of 90.
Now in other cases,
you won't see it just
in terms of atomic mass,
given in unified atomic mass units.
Sometimes in this horizontal axis,
they'll give it in terms
of mass-to-charge ratio,
where mass is the mass,
but then charge is essentially
the charge of the ions.
Now in a case where your charge is one,
for example, if you knock
one electron off of the atoms
and you have a plus-one charge,
well, then the mass-to-charge
ratio would be the same thing
as atomic mass measured in
unified atomic mass units.
If your ions have a different charge,
well, then you would have
to make the appropriate adjustment.
But in introductory chemistry class,
most of the time you will get things
in terms of just straight-up atomic mass.
If you happen to get something
in terms of mass to charge,
just make sure that if the
charge is, say, plus two,
that you make the appropriate
adjustment for the masses.
But this right over here will
tell you the various isotopes,
and it will tell you its abundance.
And it all comes from this
process of ionizing those atoms,
speeding them up, deflecting
them through a magnetic field.
And the ions that have a
higher mass-to-charge ratio
will be deflected less,
and the ions that have a
lower mass-to-charge ratio
will be deflected more.
And you can use that information
to make a graph like this.